ليست سرا ان الحديث على الجنس في عالمنا
العربي من المحرمات لكن التغيرات في
العالم تغير الوضع بشكل تام الاجابه على
الاسئله دوما هي سهل الممتنع واحيانا
يتهرب الاهل بالقول انت صغير على هذه
الاسئله وستعرف لما تكبر
لكن قصتنا اليوم من الغرب حيث تتحول مساله
التربيه الجنسيه الى ازمه بين المهاجرين
وبلادهم الجديده التربيه الجنسيه
الالزاميه تقلق العائلات العربيه نظرا
للاختلاف الثقافي والاجتماعي وقبل اسبوعين
في فرنسا رفعت منظمات حقوقيه دعاوى قضائيه
ضد الحكومه بزعب وجود مدارس غير ملتزمه
بتطبيق قانون يلزم اعطاء التلاميذ دروسا
في مجال التربيه الجنسيه فكيف يتعامل
العرب مع تدريس ابنائهم التربيه الجنسيه
في مدارس اوروبا مواد التربيه الجنسيه في
مختلف العالم وكيف يتم تقديمها مع الزميل
علاء سرحان
يتلقى التلاميذ في دول اوروبا الغربيه
والولايات المتحده وكندا واستراليا تعليما
جنسيا يبدا من مراحل مبكره ادخلت امريكا
التعليم الجنسي للمدارس في خمسينيات القرن
الماضي لكن بدايه الدعوه لادخاله كانت منذ
عام 1912 وتظل الخلافات حول محتوى هذا
التعليم ايضا التثقيف الجنسي الزامي في
معظم الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي
باستثناء بلغاريا قبرص ايطاليا ليتوانيا
بولندا ورومانيا والمملكه المتحده وفقا
لدراسه صادره عن البرلمان الاوروبي تقول
الدراسه ان المحتوى يختلف من بلد الى اخر
في النمسا مثلا يدرج الاباء في دروس
التربيه الجنسيه في هولندا تبدا التربيه
الجنسيه في سن الرابع بينما في بولندا
تكون الحياه الجنسيه من المحرمات في
المدرسه وفي اسبانيا نادرا ما يتم تدريس
هذا الموضوع في المناطق الريفيه
روسيا والهند والصين لا توجد مواد جنسيه
ضمن مناهج التعليمي هناك
[موسيقى]
ومن بيروت تنضم الينا استاذه جامعيه في
علم النفس الترب التربوي نادين جودي اهلا
بك صباح الخير ست نادين يعني السؤال الذي
يطرح نفسه دائما التربيه التربيه الجنسيه
يعني اذا حكينا عن هذه التربيه هي تبو عند
العرب وهي ماده تدرس في الغرب كيف يفسر
ذلك
يفسر ذلك هي من الاسم الخوف من الاسم كلمه
التربيه الجنسيه لحاله بيخوف الاهل واللي
ما عندهم ثقه انه يناقشوا هذا الموضوع مع
اولادهم فعشان هيك عم نشوفهم مثل ما شفنا
ريبورتاشي مؤيدين ومعارضين المعارضين هو
لسوء فهم شو يعني التربيه الجنسيه اذا بس
بناخذ مفهوم الجنس هو الذكر والانثى
والجنس موجود بالحيوانات والنباتات صار
سهل نقرب المفهوم للاهل ليتقبلوا ويحكوا
بهذا الموضوع التابوه نحن خلقناه هو مش
موجود شقنا ام ابينا التربيه الجنسيه لازم
تكون موجوده لانه الجنس هو شيء طبيعي
والكل لازم يعرف عنه
طيب بقى نادين هناك مثلا عاده ما نبدا مع
اولادنا انه نحكي لهم قصه انه اللقلق جاب
البيبي وحطه عليه باب البيت هل هذه القصص
الخرافيه صحيحه نبلش فيها مع اولادنا ولا
لازم لا نكون نقول الحقيقه بس بطريقه
علميه اكثر
ابدا ما رح ننطر للولد يبلش يفهم علينا شو
عم نحكي او نخترع بالخيال نحن التربيه
الجنسيه لازم نبدا فيها منذ الصغر لما نحن
عم نحمم الولد يكون عم يتحمم لحاله لما
بده يلبس بالبيت يكون عم يلبس لحاله مش
يركض لما يركض الولد
قدامنا بالبيت الاهل بصيروا يتبسم وبيصير
بيعتبر انه هذا الشيء كثير طبيعي فما انطر
انا لهوي يصير بعمر يسمع قصص وانا اعمل
تربيه جنسيه التربيه الجنسيه تبدا انت من
خصوصيه الولد لما الام عم بتغير للولد اول
ما يخلق مش قدام العالم هيدي تربيه جنسيه
لما يكون عم يركض بالبيت ونحن عم نضحك
ونقول له هلا ما كنا فهماني مفهوم العيب
بعدين هذه هي التربيه الجنسيه ما يتحمم مع
خيي وما يتحمم مع اخته والخيال القصص من
وين جبتك جبتك من الكيس وجبتك من السوق
كرمال ما تقلوا عن عمليه التكاثر فيها
تقرب هيدا المفهوم كتير ببساطه من خلال
الحيوانات تحكي عن قصص الحيوانات وتحكي عن
النباتات وعن التلقيح فهذا الشيء مش نوصل
لمفهوم انه نحنا
الخجل ونعبر انه من وين اجى الولد طيب كيف
اتصرف انا كاهل وخياليه كيف اتصرف كاهل
اذا وجدت ابني مثلا المراهق يتفرج على
محتوى جنسي يعني شو ممكن يكون الرد الفعل
او الرياكشن خصوصا انه هناك فجوه بين
المحتوى اللي موجود والتربيه مثل ما قلتيه
صحيح ليوصل لهذه المرحله
وما يخبر هو شو عم يعمل نحن بنكون فقدنا
فجلوا كتير سابقه قبل حتى نحن
المناقشه والحوار والحكي وعدم اخضاع الولد
قبل ما يوصل للمراهقه للطاعه طاعه
البالغين لارضائهم هذه بدنا نتجنبها لازم
نحن نفتح الحوار لحتى نحكي عن الموضوع
لازم نحكي عن الثقافه الجنسيه والتربيه
الجنسيه تدريجيه مش اعمل جلسه وارهاب وخوف
واحكي بس نهار واحد واقطع على الموضوع لو
انا تدريجيا كنت عم بحكي بالموضوع مع ابني
لمده سنوات وتكون جلسه حوار ضحك كل يوم
نحن بنمرق مسج بدنا اياها عن الحياه
الجنسيه وعن الافلام الاباحيه وعن خطورتها
ما كنا وصلنا لهم بحال صار هذا الشيء اكيد
نحن بنتجنب العقاب اكيد ونجنب التهديد
لانه هذا حيزيد بده يكون في شرح علمي في
طبيب اذا الاهل خجلانين من هذا الموضوع
ممكن زياره طبيب بجلسه وديه على عشاء على
طعمها الحكي يكون بطريقه كل يوم شوي
بطريقه مش مبطنه ولكن بطريقه عم ندخلها
بحديثنا اليوميه بالطرق علميه بدانا نحن
وصغار مع الصور في ناس رفضوا الصور طب اذا
رافضين نحن الصور للاولادنا وصغار نرجع
رافضين نحكي مع الموضوع هن وكبار وبدكن
اياهن ما يكون عندهم مشاكل فالخلل عند
الاهل
والمقاربة لحل هذا الموضوع فنحن مع انه
لما يوصل هو لابد انه يوصل لمرحله يكتشف
عن جسمه بالنطاق الخارجي لانه بلش من
داخله
ظهر للخارج وهون دورنا كاهل قبل ما تكون
بس بالمدارس اذا الاهل عم يحكوا بمنحه
والمدرسه بمنحه حنتخابط والولد حيضيع
والمعلومه حتكون ناقصه وما رح نصلحها نعم
شكرا نادين جودي كانت معنا من بيروت شكرا
على هذه المداخله